وخطيرة. وتكمن خطورتها بانها
تصدر معدلات قليلة جدا من الضجيج
الاتصالات التي تجرى خلال
المناورات المغربية يعلن الجيش
العالم? لان لا هدوء مخيف ام
لانها تصيب اهدافها سواء كانت في
عمليا بالاستفزاز لانه يدخل في
اطار التجسس والمراقبة المكشوفة.
ان ينقض على فريسته فوق اي ارض
وتحت اي سماء وفي عمق اي ماء.
لها شق طريقها بكل صمت ودون
اصدار هدير يكشف مرورها. غواصة
عقدة بحرية تحت الماء. وبسرعة
سبعة عشر عقدة فوق سطح الماء
التي تعمل بمحركات الديزل
والمحركات الكهربائية بما يكفل
رصدها من قبل العدو. برأيكم هل
تعد الثقب الاسود اخطر غواصة في
ايضا وتقطع مسافات تصل الى سبعة
الاف وخمسمائة ميل من قواعد
انطلاقها فعن اي قدرات نتحدث
لوحش روسي يمضي بصمت مطبق. قبل
الغرب اطلق على هذه الغواصة اسم
الثقب الاسود لانها مخيفة ومرعبة
الامريكي من جانبه ان الغواصة
الروسية من ضمن مجموعة الغواصات
جبل طارق حيث ظلت هناك لفترة غير
معتادة. بينما اصحاب المناورات
السفن والغواصات التي ترافق عادة
حاملات الطائرات. وخلال
ثلاثة الاف وتسعمائة وخمسين طنا
كان استفزازيا وبغرض اعتراض
مقارنة بغواصات الديزل الاخرى
ومغطاة بمواد خاصة تصعب من عملية
كبلاك هول. لا تظهر في الرادارات
رغم طولها البالغ ثلاثة وسبعين
والالمانية ودول اوروبية اخرى
مرت الغواصة بجوارها دولة بعد
البرتغال خبر مرور الغواصة
الروسية الشهيرة الثقب الاسود
المناورات مع المغرب اخيرا
اكتشفوا وجود الغواصة الحربية
مترا وبعرض عشرة امتار ليس فحسب.
بل ويمكنها الحركة بسرعة عشرين
الشهيرة التابعة للجيش الروسي
الثقب الاسود متمركزة غرب مضيق
جنوب هذا المغاربي وشمال جزر
الكناري الاسبانية يتم تصنيف ذلك
الانقاذ الروسية نيكولاي مورو.
لكن وكما يقولها المصريون ولا من
تحركاتها في المحيطات كما انها
تحمل منظومة الدفاع الجوي.
القاطرات والسفينة القاطرة
للانقاذ المسيف التابعة للقوات
بجانب حاملة طائرات دواي
تايزنهاور الامريكية حيث ترافقها
اخرى وبالقرب من شواطئها. وبرفقة
الغواصة عن بعد كانت هناك سفينة
عندها رسميا في خدمة القوات
البحرية الجزائرية واطلق على
لدرجة لا تستطيع فيها اجهزة
الناتو الفائقة الحساسية رصد
بعد ان وصلت وجهتها. اذا الى اين
اتجهت يا ترى? هنا كانت وجهتها.
راقبتها من قبل الاسبانية
والفرنسية والبريطانية
الدماء. لكن تبقى الثقب الاسود
هي ما يصدر الخوف للغربي حصلت
شاف ولا من دري. لا حس ولا خبر.
نعم لقد اعلنوا اكتشافها. لكن
بالقرب من الشواطئ البرتغالية في
طريقها الى البحر الابيض
المتوسط. وراقبت البحرية
البرتغالية الغواصة الروسية كما
طارق بالتزامن مع المناورات
العسكرية المغربية الامريكية بل
متعددة والمهام بالاضافة الى
انها مجهزة بنظام خفض الضوضاء
كهذه في منطقة قريبة نسبيا من
مسرح مناورات عسكرية كالتي جرت
وبقيت جنوب غرب المضيق مدة اكبر
من المعتاد. وعند وجود غواصة
لتنقل صحيفة ان بقاء الغواصة
المعروفة ببلاك هول التي تزن
لكنها هذه المرة وبذكاء روسي
برمجت مرورها بمنطقة مضيق جبل
العسكرية نائمون في العسل. تمضي
في تلك الطريق البحرية عادة
الغواصات اسماء الاوراس واحد
وثلاثون اثنان وثلاثون. انها
البرق الفين وواحد وعشرين
الامريكية المغربية اعلنت
الذي احس به الامريكان عام الفين
وواحد وتزامنا مع مناورات مصافحة
التجسس على التحركات الامريكية.
وهنا حان وقت الحقيقة والرعب
الاجواء البحرية. مهلا يا هذا
فلها القدرة ايضا على اكتشاف
الجزائر على اثنتين من هذه
الغواصات لترافق الغواصة سفن
تحديد الاهداف والتصويب عليها
قبل حتى ان يلتقطها الرادار. يا
قصة تسلح الرعب المتطور مستمرة
بالجزائر ابتداء بنظام اسكندر
مرورا بنظام الصواريخ كورنيت اي
ام ووصولا الى الراجمة مصاص
الاسود التي تنثر الرعب باعماق
البحار ومنذ ذلك الحين ما زالت
مجنحة مع مدى فعالية يصل الى
الفين وخمسمائة كيلو متر. هي
الجزائر. كل تلك المواصفات
والقصة لم تبدأ بعد يا اصدقاء
البحرية الجزائرية واتجهت الى
مكان الانتشار الدائم لتدخل
الاطلسي اسم الثقب الاسود والسبب
واضح وهو قدرتها المميزة على
لها من قدرات خارقة. فامريكا
تتباهى بدقة راداراتها لتكشف
غواصة تختبئ في احشائها اسلحة
عابرة للقارات. الغواصة تصل
تحركت الجزائر احدى اخطر
الغواصات بالعالم. غواصة الثقب
عسكرية وصفت بالحساسة. يطلق
عليها خبراء البحرية في حلف شمال
لتبدأ حكاية قوتها مع اواخر خريف
عام الفين وثمانية عشر عندما
المناورة تحت الماء حيث انها
مجهزة بمعدات كاليبر والصوار
التخفي تحت الماء عن باقي
الغواصات. بالاضافة الى قدرات
احد شواطئ الولايات المتحدة
لتتسلم القوات الروسية احداثيات
الاستخبارات الروسية في وقت لاحق
عن ان هذه الغواصة اتمت متى في
يوما. وما هذه الا البداية.
فيمكنها اصابة الاهداف البرية
والبحرية من تحت الماء. هنا لا
يعلم العدو من اين يتلقى
الضربات. وتحمل ايضا صواريخ ذكية
تستطيع اسقاط اي طائرة في
الاهداف على بعد ثلاثة او اربعة
اضعاف انظمة الرادار. لتستطيع
تحت الماء في عمق يصل الى
ثلاثمائة متر ولمدة خمسة واربعين
وهم اعضاء طاقمها. لكن ما هو
اعظم هو انها قادرة على البقاء
وقد فات الاوان لتتصاعد الادخنة
معلنة عن تدمير هدفها. مهلا مهلا
على التخفي تماما. ولا تستطيع
الرادارات المضادة اكتشافها الا
نحن لم نبدأ بعد. فالثقب الاسود
كافية لتحمل اثنين وخمسين فرد
مليمتر وصواريخ كاليبر حيث تتميز
الغواصات من هذا الطراز بقدرتها
دعونا نتحدث اولا عن ثقب بوتين
الاسود. فيليجي نوف جرو او ما
العالم لهذا اليوم الاسود? اذا
قبل ان نتحدث عن اليوم الاسود
اعلن الدب الروسي حربه التي
احرقت الاخضر واليابس. يتفاجأ
التخفي وهي احد وحوش بوتين التي
ترسو بجانب اسطول البحر الاسود.
العالم بنوعية اسلحة قد تقود
العالم لحافة الهاوية. فهل تحضر
تعج بالمفاجآت المرعبة. والتي لم
نكتشفها او نتعمق بها الا بعد ان
والمحيطات. وتستطيع المكوث مئات
الامتار تحت الماء لاكثر من خمسة
خطر. اختصار ثكنة عسكرية متنقلة
عن غواصة الثقب الاسود نتحدث
هذه الغواصة مسلحة بطربيدات من
عيار خمسمائة وثلاثة وثلاثين
تسمى بالثقب الاسود هي احدث
غواصة من سلسلة الغواصات فائقة
واربعين يوما تضرب اهدافها برا
وبحرا وجوا وبدقة عالية دون اي
تحديد مكانها الى هذه اللحظة
تناور بمهارة في اعماق البحار
نوعها. جميع الرادارات تخر سريعة
امامها دون ان تستطيع كشفها او
رصدت عدة القاب مرعبة منها
مفترسة المحيط وشبح البحار
واليكم بقية القصة. مع صعود
بوتين للحكم اصبحت مخازن روسيا
بكتلة ظلام وتتجول في احشاء
المحيط دون ان تسمع ضجيج
محركاتها. سكنت لاشهر في مياه
الاعداء دون ان يعلم بوجودها.
خذها الجزائر كعربون صداقة. اذا
فما هي هديتك يا بوتين? هي اشبه
البر ام في البحر ام في الجو?
واشهرها بلاك هول او الثقب
الاسود. نعم هي روسية فريدة من